[Music]  this is tammy and lucho  they're commandoers  and this is their first date  [Music]  when a tamandawa feels threatened it  will rear up on its hind legs and use  its sharp powerful claws to slash out  sometimes it can be hard to break the  ice  tamandewers are the smaller cousin of  the giant anteater  and while both species enjoy snacking on  ants tamanduas are excellent tree  climbers while their larger relatives  prefer to stay firmly on the ground  tamandras have excellent defense  mechanisms for enemies both large and  small  if a predator gets too close the  tamandua will release a powerful stinky  spray four times as strong as a skunk  and its thick coarse fur keeps angry  ants from reaching its skin when dining  at an ant hill  despite these protective adaptations the  temanua remains a threatened species in  their native central and south america  habitat loss and hunting are both  looming threats  this is the timandwa  you